ان معنا صحفيه ميس عواد ميس اهلا
كيف صرتي بخمت اكثر من مره كيف نقيم الوضع
في اكياس الان في ضخمه عفوا
بالحرج هل سقوط بالتالي هذه المدينه
كما تقول وهذا الوصف ليس مجانيا لانه يؤشر
الى عده مع المعلومات اولها ربما تحضير
الراي العام الاوكراني لانسحاب من بخموت
ولكن ايضا هناك نقطه مهمه يجب اخذها في
عين الاعتبار لها علاقه بالتركيز الاعلامي
الشديد على على مخمود هناك محللون عسكريون
كانوا قد تحدثوا خلال الايام الماضيه ان
التركيز بشكل كبير على مخموت قد يكون هدفه
وهنا نقول قد
التركيز الانظار على هذه المدينه بهدف
القيام بعمليات اخرى اما شمالا والى جنوب
واما جنوبا وربما من هنا ايضا نستطيع حتى
ان نقرا هذا الهجوم على شبه جزيره القرم
الذي اعلنت عنه
الجهات الروسيه لكن لنعود الى مدينه بخموت
هذه اخر المعطيات الاكيد ان الوضع فعلا
معقد لكن هذا الامر ليس بجديد ولو ان
الخناق يضيق على المدينه المدينه كما نرى
باتت شمالا وشرقا وجنوبا محاصره واذا
قارنا مع الاسابيع الماضيه فان كل هذه
المنطقه مثلا لم تكن في ظل السيطره
الروسيه ما حدث خلال الايام والاسابيع
الماضيه عاملان اساسيان هنا هناك طريقان
اساسيان كان يستخدمان سابقا من قبل الجيش
الاوكراني لتزويد خطوط المدينه اتحدث عن
خط ام صفر ثلاثه وخط اخر هو تي 0513 كان
يلتقيان قرابه بلده هنا تسمى كرسمه هره
عندما سيطرت عليها القوات الروسيه فقدنا
تماما بالنسبه الى الجيش الاوكراني وهذا
ما قالوه لنا هذان الطريقان كانت هناك
ايضا طريق عمليا تقطع المدينه هكذا
اتحدث عن الطريق تي ثلاثه عشر هذه ايضا
تحت السيطره
الروسيه الطريق الوحيده التي لا تزال شبه
تحت السيطره الاوكرانيه هي طريق تاتي من
هنا نراها حتى هذه مع السيطره القوات
الروسيه على كل هذه المناطق بشكل محكم
باتت تحت الضرب عندما كنت في كاب الاسبوع
الماضي التقيت
بمسؤول قائد لواء في بخموت قال لي عده
نقاط قد تفيدنا في فهم ما يجري اولا حتى
الطريق السالكه
قافلات السيارات اصبح هناك صعوبه بتسييرها
جماعه جامعات لانهم يعلمون انه عند حدوث
اي ضربه لا يريدون خسارات كبيره هذه نقطه
النقطه الثانيه عندما سالته ما الذي
ينقصكم في بخموت قال لي تنقصنا الذخيره عن
واحده من اليوميات التي يعيشها قال مثلا
خذنا قتالا عنيفا مع احدى فرق فاغنر
وانتصرنا استطعنا ان نقترب من الموقع
وعندما اعترضنا التواصل اللاسلكي مع
الجانب الروسي اكتشفنا انهم سيررسلون ثلاث
فرق الى الموقع نفسه لكم ان تتخيلوا حجم
الضغط انهكت القوات الاوكرانيه لم يعد
لديها ذخيره وفي الجانب الاخر يسمعون ان
هناك تعزيزات من قبل
الجانب الروسي بمعنى اخر وبشكل واضح بين
الذخيره المتوافره في الجانب الروسي غير
متوافره بكثافه بالجانب الاوكراني والقدره
على تغيير الفرق بالطبع الافضليه
الجانب الروسي ايضا من النقاط المهمه عدم
سالته تتحدثون عن مخموت القلعه لكن باي
ثمن دوره قطعناه بالدموع كانت لحظه جدا
متشرده قال نحن لا نناقش ولا يمكن ان
نناقش الاوامر التي تاتي من فوق ولا
يمكننا ان نقول هذه مدينه غير استراتيجيه
سوف نتخلى عنها وعندها اين سيصبح خط
التوقف اليوم نترك مخمود غدا كريمه ثم
نذهب الى كيف هذه هي ما يجعل الارض اليوم
كان هناك فيديو انتشر على وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي بعدما قيل هذا ما نرى هذا جندي
اوكراني حرص على وضع تاريخ اليوم في مدينه
بخموت ويقول التالي القتال مستمر في
الضواحي المدفعيه مستمره نحن في بخموت لا
احد سيغادر الى اي مكان لا نزال نقف هنا
ولكن نقف هنا مع طرق امداد كما راينا على
الخارطه ضيق الغايه وبكثير من الخسائر
البشريه منذ بدايه هذه الحرب طبعا يقومون
بشراسه ولكن سقوط ضخمه يبدو متوقعا وواشكا
في حال تم ذلك ما التبعات على الاوكران
هناك تبعات عسكريه وتبعات سياسيه تبعات
العسكريه قد لا تكون كبيره لكن سقوط مخمود
سوف يفتح الباب على الذهب غربا الى
كراماتو رزق وهذا يفعل من قوه هذا الهجوم
الروسي الذي رايناه قد بدا منذ مده اما
سياسيا المفاعيل ستكون كبيره جدا لانه
سيكون هناك سؤال يوجه الى الرئيس زيلينسكي
نفسه على قاعده اي ثمن لهذه الحرب
السياسيه والاعلاميه التي خيضت فيما يسمى
بقلعه الاوكرانيين حتى اللحظه الاوكرانيون
متمسكون ورفضوا نصائح الامريكيين التي
اوحت لهم بضروره الخروج من المدينه شكرا
لك ميساء عوض على هذه المداخله